JOSH BERNSTEIN: My name's
Josh Bernstein.
I am a Brooklyn-based journalist
and author, and
I've been writing about beer,
food, spirits, and travel in
New York City for about,
gosh, 12 years now.
And that really wasn't my
original career trajectory.
I didn't really end up wanting
to come to New York
City to be a writer.
But after I graduated college,
I went on a road trip across
the country.
And it was one of those failed
collegiate road trips.
I ended up getting dropped
off in the middle of
Great Falls, Montana.
And which was really poetic--
first day of fall.
So being 21 years old, I was
like, this is awesome.
And so, the rest of my life
is in front of me.
But I didn't really
know what to do.
And so, I had two choices--
I could call friends in--
where was it--
they were in Albuquerque,
and friends in Boulder.
So my friends in Boulder picked
up the phone first, and
I went there for a few weeks.
But living in someone's
basement, drinking beer all
day long is awesome, but
also not really a
great career path.
And so my friend in New York
City called me up, and he's
like, Josh, we got a spare
bedroom in Astoria.
Do you want to come live there
for free for two months?
And I was like, sure.
So I got on a bus, travelled
across the country.
And then got to Astoria.
And then I didn't really
know what I was
going to do, either.
I went to school.
I had a magazine journalism
degree, but that doesn't
really mean anything at all.
And really, it means you've
graduated from college.
And then, as I quickly found
out, a journalism degree
didn't really matter worth
a darn in New York.
I went to Ohio University,
which is supposed to be a
prestigious journalism school.
But in New York, people are just
like, I don't really care
what you did, Ohio boy.
And so I temped.
And I temped, and I temped,
and I temped for, gosh,
several years.
I was a temp receptionist,
then I was--
well, back track a little bit.
Do you want the real story?
So basically, it's mildly
embarrassing, but it's like
the foolhardy choices you make
when you're in early 20's.
And so I got a job at "American
Baby" magazine for a
few months, basically
filing papers.
And so I was like, journalism,
"American
Baby," this is great.
But it wasn't very
rewarding at all.
And so at the time, my friend
was working for a porn
publishing company.
And he was like, Josh, do you
want to work at this porn
publishing company
as an editor?
And I was like, why
the hell not?
I'm 22 years old.
So I spent the next eight months
working for a porn
publisher, which, I mean, the
initial hilarity of it all
kind of fell away.
I mean, the job was built
on three parts.
One was about--
there was a magazine, "Hot
Chocolate" and "Cuddles." One
was young black girls.
One was young white girls.
So I was in charge of
interviewing porn stars.
And then the other part was
there's all these books called
chapbooks--
basically 5 and a 1/2 by 8 and
1/2, black and white newsprint
books filled with all
this really terrible
writing about porn.
And my job was to go through
them all and modernize it.
It was thematically oriented to
horny housewives, naughty
neighbors, family secrets--
terrible,
terrible, terrible stuff.
And so it was my job all day
long to modernize it, and also
find the pictures
that go with it.
And so after about--
which this is a really terrible
job back then.
I was getting paid-- it was like
fifteen bucks an hour.
But I was like, I'm making,
$15 an hour.
But you'd be in this small
office with eight people.
And it was run by this
Caribbean woman.
She'd want to come
and hug you.
And you'd have to review porn
on VHS in her office.
And it was just really wrong
in so many ways.
But then I didn't really realize
it how long it was.
But then, after-- our
offices were below
Canal Street on Broadway.
But then after 9/11, basically
we couldn't go to
work for two weeks.
So I came back to work.
And then, my boss was like,
oh, it's sucks you
couldn't go to work.
Let's take it out of
your vacation time.
And I was like, out of
my vacation time?
I mean, there was this
natural disaster,
everything terrible happened.
And it was my vacation time,
because we are obviously
drinking pina coladas all day
long when this is happening.
And so, I started looking
for other jobs.
My boss found my resume
on my computer.
And then I came back from work--
or from lunch one day,
then all my files
are wiped off.
And I was like, I'm not going to
get fired from a porn job.
And so she called me in her
office, so I quit right then.
Got me two weeks notice there.
She gave me a severance check.
So kind of from that moment
forward, I was like, you know
what, I'm really going to
make the writing happen.
So I started temping.
I was the world's worst
receptionist, making like $10
an hour, answering phones,
wearing the
same tie all day long.
But then I was--
kept on trying to pitch
magazines, newspapers--
no one cared.
And I really started thinking
what I was really passionate.
I've always been a big--
I've always loved food, always
been adventuring in the city
to try to find delicious
stuff.
And I also liked
going to bars.
And so, after pitching
[INAUDIBLE], which was an alt
weekly that, unfortunately,
expired last year, for a
number of years they gave me a
weekly column where I got to
write about my food and drink
adventures in New York.
And so that led to working for
"Time Out New York" as their
bar reviewer.
Then, like, slowly, bit by bit
by bit, I started getting more
and more and more gigs.
Started working for "Gourmet"
as their beer writer.
The magazine in Portland called
"Imbibe," they hired me
to be their beer writer.
And so my career track kind of
slowly, steadily started going
into getting drunk and
writing about it.
Which wasn't exactly a bad
thing, but then going to bars
all night long is really
kind of tough in being
a reviewer of that.
So as the days went on, I tried
to find a way to kind of
happen to get out, and go out
before 4 in the morning,
because 4 in the morning
at 25 is awesome.
4 in the morning at 29, and 30,
31, when you have a wife,
it's just really not as
cool as it used to be.
And so, I kind of started moving
in to writing more
generally about craft beer.
And this was maybe about 2005.
And at that time in America,
we'd gone through, in the
'90s, craft beer--
there was this really big push
toward craft beer in the '90s.
There was brands everywhere.
Sierra Nevada was really
going gangbusters.
Dogfish Head came on line.
All these great breweries, but
then everything kind of burst.
And everyone thought that
this was a big trend
that was going away.
And that craft beer is just
another fly-by-night fad.
But what started happening in
the early 2000s was people
came into it with much
better business plans
that, instead of--
and the market was really
flooded with all this extra
equipment, because everyone that
failed, they spent all
their money on really great
equipment, and then they
didn't need it anymore.
And so all these better
entrepreneurs bought all this
used equipment with the lower
barrier to entry.
And so craft beer really started
taking off all across
the country.
And so I started writing
about it.
And then, what I soon found
out about what I really
enjoyed about writing about
craft beer is that you get in
on honest story from people.
I mean, when I was younger,
I used to do celebrity
journalism, too.
You'd have to do dumb stuff that
sounds really great, like
interviewing Hugh Hefner,
the guys from "Jackass."
Which, ostensibly,
is a dream thing.
But the more I did that, the
more I realized that you would
never really get true
conversations with people.
And there was really
just a lot of--
it was like going to do an
interview, and having--
pushing a button, and people
will recite everything to you.
And it was really
disheartening.
I mean, as someone that really
wanted to talk to people, get
great conversations, and tell
their stories, it just--
it never worked out.
And so what I found with craft
beer, though, is craft brewing
is such a passionate industry.
It's something that's really
about-- it's your personal.
It's DIY.
It's blue collar.
It's something that people are
really proud about it.
And the people that are out
there doing craft brewing,
they're putting everything
on the line.
I mean, these are people that
have found a way to turn their
hobby into a career.
And it's something they're so
incredibly proud of, and they
want to share their stories.
And so, what I started realizing
was it wasn't as
much about the hops, the ABV,
the geekiness about these
beers, and more, really,
about the people.
And so whenever I decided to
write about craft beer, I
always think about craft beer,
the people behind the beer,
behind the beer bottle.
And that's really what
I started focusing on
feature-wise.
So then, the book came about
in a totally random way.
This publisher, Sterling--
I kind of wanted to
write a book.
But writing a book and actually
doing it are two
different things altogether.
And you have to pitch people.
You have to get queries
out there.
You have to get a publisher
interested.
I luckily didn't have to do
any of that, which I feel
entirely lucky.
What basically happened was this
publisher, Sterling, they
were looking to write some--
they were looking to hire
some beer book authors.
And they originally
came to me.
They found my columns in New
York Press I swear to God, I
mean, the guy, that publisher
that picked up my alt weekly
things was sitting on the subway
or something, and saw
my column and then
wrote to me.
I think it was as
random as that.
And then, originally they're
going to have me do a book
about stouts, which
it wouldn't be the
most exciting thing.
But it was really this
great opportunity to
kind of do a book.
But then I was--
I was kind of a yes man.
I was like, sure, whatever
you want me to do.
You're going to pay
me to be a writer.
This is awesome.
But the more I thought about
that, with so much change
going on in the country, and so
much change going on craft
beer, that actually writing a
book about stouts is really a
disservice to what's
been happening.
And so I came back with
another idea.
And that was really to tell the
story about what's been
happening all across the
country, traveling from
Portland to Portland, small
towns in Iowa, Texas.
And just talking about the
flowering of craft beer, and
showing how America--
America, in a way, we don't
make a lot things that the
world cares about anymore.
The cars get slagged,
electronics--
but craft beer, in this really
weird way, has been something
that's been a guiding
light for people
all around the world.
You have--
I was on the radio last
night with this
guy, Yeppi, from Denmark.
And basically, he was
totally inspired by
American-style beers.
And so he decided to make an
entire business plan of
emulating American beers, and
making really wild, delicious
flavorful things.
And you see this echoed
in Norway.
You see it echoed in England.
And so America, in a great way,
is really leading the
world with this product that--
it seems silly, and
seems frivolous.
But what I like about beer is
beer brings people together.
And that-- what craft
beer does, more
than anything else--
it used to be you'd go to a bar,
if you talked to someone,
they'd be like, what're
you drinking?
Beer.
Beer was beer.
But now, what craft beer is
great about, I think, it
really helps people start
a conversation.
Because there's so much--
and people want to share
their passion it.
And craft beer has such a
low barrier to entry.
You can spend two bucks and
be transported to a really
flavorful world.
Like, the best beer in
the world can be
bought for two bucks.
You can't say that about
many other things.
Wine?
Two bucks-- that's Two
Buck Chuck is a joke.
You can't even buy-- like two
bucks will buy a little
airplane bottle of liquor.
But I mean, beer--
$2.
And that's the thing about it.
It's a great democratizing
beverage.
And so that was it.
So I traveled across the
country, and really told the
story of all the brewers, their
passion, creativity.
And really, their struggle to
change the way that America
drinks one beer at the time.
So the beer--
the book on beer came out
at November 2011.
So I've been on a book tour
pretty much for the last 14
months, give or take.
Which is--
the one thing that no one ever
tells you that, when you write
a book is that you have
to become a salesman.
You stop being a writer, and
you have to go out and
actually do those things.
So I had to go there, go
to beer festivals.
Be behind the counter
smiling, and hoping
people want take a look.
But it's really been a totally
rewarding ride, and it's--
you know, I wouldn't give
it up for anything.
It's been really great.
And writing a book is not fun.
Doing the selling is not fun.
But what's really excellent is
to see the book in people's
hands, to see the responses,
and just get
all this great feedback.
And people emailing
me, telling me how
they feel about it.
That really makes it
all worthwhile.
The year and a half of writing
and editing, it just doesn't
feel like anything.
So that's kind of it
in a nut shell.
And one of the other people
we have here today is--
the New York craft
beer scene is--
used to be kind of crappy.
I'll be blunt.
There were more craft breweries
in the '90s in New
York City than there are now.
I mean, you had this place
called Nacho Mama's in SoHo.
There was a brewery in
Rockefeller Center.
There was even a Times
Square brewery.
But all these people, they
really failed because they
were terrible beer, bad business
plans-- everything
conspired together.
And so, we had Brooklyn Brewery
as one of the few
leading lights in the city.
And then we also had--
Sixpoint came along in Brooklyn
a few years ago.
And besides that, there
was really not much
of anything at all.
But what's really great is, in
the last few months, you've
seen about four or five
breweries open up in Queens.
You have Rockaway Brewing based
in Long Island City.
You have--
oh gosh--
there's a kombucha brewery
in Astoria.
And then, you have SingleCut,
which is actually New York's
newest and biggest
brewery, too.
And so, they are going to be
here to pour samples for
everyone, so.
AUDIENCE: What's your
favorite beer?
JOSH BERNSTEIN: Oh gosh,
that's a question that
everyone always gets.
You know, the easy, dumb answer
is, whatever is in
front of me.
But if I'm going to be drinking
all day long, I
usually go for a nice,
crisp pilsner.
Something like--
I like Victory Prima Pils which
is really crisp, fresh,
low alcohol.
And also, the secret weapon at
Trader Joe's is Trader Joe's
actually-- their house brand,
Mission Street, is actually
made by Firestone Walker.
And if anyone knows Firestone
Walker, they're actually one
of the world's best breweries.
And so, you're get-- their beers
win medals every year at
the Great American Beerfest,
which is kind of
the Olympics of beer.
And so, you're talking, you can
get that for $6.99 in a
six pack there for that.
And it's like 4.6%.
And so, I often drink
that a parties.
That's kind of--
it's awesome.
AUDIENCE: On that same topic,
why do we not see more
consolidation.
I'm always surprised that some
of these bigger breweries
acquire someone [INAUDIBLE].
Seems like a really
good target for--
I'm not saying I want
this to happen.
But like, if I'm InBev or like--
because we see them go
out and buying other brands.
Like, why not acquire some
of these craft breweries?
JOSH BERNSTEIN: I mean, we
got to-- you have to--
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah, I know
Goose Island is like the one
that [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH BERNSTEIN: You
have to sell.
You have to want to sell, too.
And so, I mean, it's like if
you've built up this project
from the ground up, it's
your baby, it's your
dream, it's your life.
And I mean, it's your identity
is wrapped up in it.
And so--
I mean, Goose Island was
that they were--
Goose Island was a big
Chicago brewery, been
around 20-plus years.
They got bought by
Anheuser-Busch recently.
And so, what ended up happening
was, you can say on
one end that they are sell-outs
for doing it.
But on the other hand, it was
run by a family that worked
for 20-plus years, and they
wanted to try something new.
And so, they got paid
a fair value.
And the son went on to run--
start a cider company.
And the dad got out.
AUDIENCE: I'm not
going to hold it
against any of the brewers.
It's more--
JOSH BERNSTEIN: You'd be
amazed-- you'd be amazed how
much people hold it
against brewers.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] is that
beer is no longer craft beer.
JOSH BERNSTEIN: You know, craft
beer is such a nebulous
term nowadays.
AUDIENCE: Technically that
would be [INAUDIBLE].
That term "craft" just implies
that from small batches, and
that it's hand-made.
JOSH BERNSTEIN: That's such
an interesting thing.
Craft beer--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH BERNSTEIN: Yeah, craft
beer, the brewers'
association, which is kind of
the industry watch-group, has
really been fighting the
definition of craft beer, and
what it means for people.
And so, there's a big battle
about what to actually call a
beer like that.
And, I mean, it's just--
I like to get to a place where
it's just beer that you don't
have to make distinctions.
That it's just like that.
But if you think back to the
'90s, it was "microbrew," and
no one uses the phrase
"microbrew" anymore.
So you've seen a generational
shift in the way that people
perceive it.
And what's interesting, as well,
is with the craft beer,
it's just that there used to
be no differentiation, that
people are like you
just drink beer.
And so now, people that--
what I've been noticing going
around and talking to folks,
people that like their crappy
beer, they're like--
they call it crappy beer.
Like, oh yeah, I'm drinking
my thirty-pack of Busch.
I'm drinking my crappy beer.
And you would never call
it crappy beer before.
It was just beer.
So there is this cut in the
marketplace in a way people
are thinking about actually
how beer is perceived.
And so, by the way, definitely
how to call crap
beer, that's a--
people are fighting
about that.
They will always, so.
AUDIENCE: I want to get your
opinion on breweries like
Mikkeller or [INAUDIBLE]
gypsy that travel around
and use other people's
[INAUDIBLE].
JOSH BERNSTEIN: [INAUDIBLE],
so basically, there's this
concept in craft brewing about
gypsy brewers-- which I wrote
about in "Brewed Awakening."
But anyways.
So what happens, there so
opening a brewery cost
millions of dollars--
I mean, cost tons of money.
You're basically sinking--
you've got to take
out a bank loan.
You gotta do everything.
You can easily go broke before
even brewing your first beer.
And so, the thing about
breweries is that they operate
best like airplanes--
like the more they are-- they
should be used as frequently
as possible to the
fullest capacity.
And so, for people-- breweries
have excess capacity behooves
them to rent out their
extra space.
And so gypsy brewers
have kind of--
they're finding this loophole
where they're able to go on
these systems without actually
investing in a big brewery.
But they can go there
and brew the beers.
And I think that allows them
to have a lot of freedom to
make the beers they want to
do without having to--
you know, you can try
a one-off batch.
You can do something that
allows for a lot of
excitement.
And a lot of these gypsy
breweries, they do dozens of
different styles, travel around
the world, do a lot of
collaborations.
And, I think, I personally
love it.
What was interesting, Yeppi,
from Evil Twin.
We are basically-- he's
actually-- he moved to
Brooklyn, actually, all the
way from Denmark to there.
And he's actually starting,
going to be contract brewing
out of Connecticut.
So you're seeing some of the
gypsy brewers take root
because, after a while, trying
to find space, and always
trying to find--
that can be a full time
job trying to
juggle capacity issues.
And what's to say if a brewery
gets big, they can be like,
you know what, I can make more
money selling my own beer then
of renting out this
space to you.
So at its best, a
gypsy brewer--
it's a tenuous proposition
that could
collapse at any minute.
AUDIENCE: It's gotta
be short-term, too.
Gotta get in and get out.
JOSH BERNSTEIN: You've got
to get in, get out.
And you have to have a
distributor set up, and
distributors that can pick it
up from all these breweries,
which, if you're working with
great distributors like
Mikkeller or Evil Twin,
you can deal with it.
But if you're a smaller
person, you have to--
selling the beer is
the biggest thing.
And you have to have people
that are going
to sell it for you.
You can't just go into
a brewery and do it.
What do people think
about the beer?
What are you guys drinking?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] did the
custom beer for their
Christmas party.
Is that a common theme
[INAUDIBLE]
companies or individual
[INAUDIBLE] do custom one-off
batches for like weddings
or parties?
JOSH BERNSTEIN: I will say,
you know, a lot of--
you're going to see--
there's a lot of custom one-off
batches in New York City.
Sixpoint and Brooklyn Brewery
do a bunch of stuff with the
Danny Meyer chain.
It's pretty common.
It's a way for them to--
it used to be if you wanted to
have your own brand on there,
you just by really crappy beer,
and just call it your
house beer or something like
that, which-- but nowadays,
restaurants are really
seeing a viable--
you know, you want to give
your customer the best
experience possible.
So you're finding that it's
pretty commonplace nowadays.
You dig down, like
Shake Shack.
Shake Shack's got the beer
from Brooklyn Brewery.
And I think Brooklyn Brewery did
some stuff for our Thomas
Keller's restaurants, too.
And so this is pretty
commonplace all across the
country now, you're
going to find.
It's a great way to do
a different beer.
But as far as for, like a
wedding, or something like
that, you have to register
all these brands.
So it depends what-- every
state has different
registration fees.
And so, most people are not
going to brew a beer for your
wedding, unfortunately.
AUDIENCE: So you sort of
hinted at that the beer
distributor network thing, which
I heard-- there's an
interesting article recently
claiming-- well, it's really
the road to high barrier
to entry.
But it was saying it also helps
protect the distribution
channel for small breweries.
If we didn't have the regulation
with all the
distributors, that it would be
really be harder to get your
beer into stores.
But of course, barriers to
entry are often that, so
[INAUDIBLE].
So do you think it's
good or not?
AUDIENCE: All you have to do is
watch where the lobbyist's
money is coming from.
It's not coming from
the little guys.
JOSH BERNSTEIN: So the barriers
to entry can be--
the barriers to entry to
get your-- to go with a
distribution chain can
be really crazy.
One of the great things is, for
smaller breweries, you're
able to do--
I think it's up to--
I can't remember what it is in
New York-- where you're able
to self-distribute up to a
certain amount, so you get to
bypass that.
And so, ideally, once you grow
big enough, you'll jump into
that chain because, you know,
distributing beer yourself
gets you more money per
keg and all that.
But you also have to distribute
it yourself.
And so, you have to figure out
what the best use of your
resources are.
Is it getting into a truck
and driving it someplace?
Or is it paying someone
else to get in a truck
and drive it someplace?
But I really believe
if you're--
distributors are snapping up
brands left and right, because
they want to have variety.
They want to have scope.
They want to have the hot,
new brand in New York.
And especially in New York City,
I think of how New York
is kind of a weird
show pony city.
That we do have 8 million people
in town, 19 million
metro area, 50 million tourists
coming through.
And you can reach a lot of
eyeballs with your brand if
you get your beer into
New York City.
And people-- what Mark was
talking about, where you out
before the morning people come
to New York to go out and
enjoy themselves.
And so, I mean, it's a market
where you push a lot of beer.
And the other interesting
about the New York City
market, though, is that we're
not really a town that buys
beer and goes home as much
as we drink most of
our beer out in public.
And so, with the city as our
living room, and the bar as
our living room.
And so that's really
been a big--
a lot of brands that come into
New York City, it's kind of
rude awakening that they're
not going to sell beer in
bottles as much as they're going
to sell beer on draught
and in growlers, so.
AUDIENCE: Do you homebrew?
JOSH BERNSTEIN: I'll answer
your question first.
No, I don't homebrew
I know, it's like
I'm a terrible person.
But you know what, I I've been
doing these homebrew tours for
3 and 1/2 years now.
And everyone's always like,
why don't you homebrew?
And I'm like, do you know how
much of my days to beer-- and
I have a very lovely,
tolerant wife.
But you know, I spend all
of my days writing
about beer and food.
And at the end of the day,
I just don't have it.
And it's just like--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
one more thing.
JOSH BERNSTEIN: It's like
It's like, I want to relax
and have a beer.
But you know what, I've
homebrewed with friends
before, and it's pretty
awesome, but I just--
I'm not doing it right now.
But it does, it makes
me seem like a bad
person to some people.
You're not really authentic.
It's truly is.
And things are like--
it's wild.
But I'm always, like, does
everyone who writes about
spirits make their
own bourbon?
Do wine writers crush all
their own grapes?
But it's kind of like, I think,
that it's just because
homebrewing is something
everyone can do, that people
expect you to do it, too.
Because they can do it, you
should be doing it.
You should be doing it
better than them.
But I don't.
So, that's one of
the ways I fail.
Your hand was up?
AUDIENCE: So between a good
craft beer [INAUDIBLE].
Have you seen this happening for
other foods, like cheese
and bread, [INAUDIBLE]?
JOSH BERNSTEIN: Oh, I mean,
it's like, yeah.
I mean, I can just--
I live in Crown Heights, and
I've been there 10 years, back
when it was just--
your corner bodegas, you're
lucky to get a $0.99 can of
Coors Light, and you're
just like,
awesome, this great variety.
Nowadays, their stocking Bear
Republic IPAs, and like a
really good, sprouted
organic bread.
And I mean, it is a general
upswing, this idea that we--
people are understanding that
great products don't cost a
lot of money, and there are
stigmas in a way that's--
you're paying $2 for a loaf of
Wonder Bread, and $4 for a
loaf of great bread.
I mean, it's people are
realizing that like these
little luxuries really make
a big difference in life.
And so I think they really
do go hand in hand.
AUDIENCE: It seems somewhat
common, too, but I'd like to
just know what your thoughts are
on limiting distributions
as a marketing technique.
I mean, the Heady-Topper
is a perfect example.
It's a number one-rated
beer around the world.
You can only get it in
northern Vermont.
I've had it.
I'm not saying it's not
an amazing beer.
But I think there's some element
of hype to that.
JOSH BERNSTEIN: Oh,
that's all.
That's why was I
talking about--
preaching locally, drink.
I mean, there's a million
great beers
out there right now.
And I mean, there's these things
they call the white
whales, which every
goes after them.
Like, Three Floyds has a beer
called the Dark Lord, an
imperial stout.
And Russian River's got
Pliny the Elder, this
amazing double IPA.
It's almost like a geek feedback
loop, like the more
people rave about it, the more
people want to get it, and
everyone wants to drink
it and so--
They're great beers, but never--
you know, I've got
this thing, I'd never wait
in line for a beer.
I mean, that's a
terrible thing.
And I never jump through
hoops for that.
They're great if you can try
them, don't get me wrong.
But it's just there's so many
other beers out there that are
worth trying I think.
Like, I was up in Vermont.
I did get some Heady-Topper,
but it was a pain
in the ass to get.
And I was like, why the hell?
I'm not going to drive to
the brewery 40 minutes
just to get his beer.
And I had to go to the co-op
right when they got the
shipment in.
I'm like, this is silly.
I did it anyway.
But I was in Vermont.
I was like, I have to do--
and it was actually a snow--
there was a blizzard that day.
I'm like, I have to get
drunk in a hotel room.
But anyway, yeah, don't
ever go after it.
That's my advice.
If you get it in your
hands, great.
If not, there's a lot of other
beers that are going to make
you really happy.
AUDIENCE: You're going to a
new city, how do you find
local beers?
Do you do your research
beforehand?
Or just kind of contact
friends there?
JOSH BERNSTEIN: A little bit A
and B. For finding great local
breweries, I do a fair
amount of research.
And I also go into my network
of friends, and
just check it out.
I think craft breweries, in
a sense, really get a--
you really get a great flavor.
The little brew pubs in town,
the great flavor of people.
And so you can find out so much
by bending elbows at the
bar, and just talking
to people.
So I do a ton of research before
I ever get to a city.
I use a lot of social
media aspects.
I go on Twitter, and that's
great for crowd-sourcing
suggestions, and so on.
Which I did for my
trip to Vermont.
And then also, it's like I reach
out to brewers that I
know, and I ask them like
what's worth seeking out
there, and so.
My trips now are basically
beer and food-based.
Which is not a bad thing, but
I try to round it out a bit.
But really, it is, it's so
exciting to go to these new
cities, and try all the beers.
And I want to--
it really just gives a great
scope of what's been happening
across American.
And I really enjoy it.
Beer tourism is growing by leaps
and bounds everywhere.
And I think--
I mean, cities are smart, and
they're doing great things
like having ale trails
that are doing--
and gosh, Vermont, you can get
a punch card for all the
breweries you should go to.
Same thing in Portland,
Maine--
Oregon, I mean.
Beer tourism is really--
it's an awesome way
that things are going.
I don't have a beer in my
hand and everyone's
drinking around me.
This is like the exact
opposite of how
things usually are.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSH BERNSTEIN: I'll start
with the Olympic White.
Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: You know where
you can get one.
JOSH BERNSTEIN: What?
AUDIENCE: You know where
you can get one.
JOSH BERNSTEIN: I know.
We got 'em.
So how did you come up with the
path that's [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH BERNSTEIN: Oh yeah.
If anyone hasn't-- if anyone
picked up a book, and saw, we
actually have a--
we'll do with that.
Which, actually the cover comes
out, becomes a map, so
look at that.
Oh.
The cover comes off,
becomes a map.
And so, the idea of was,
it's this company
called Pop Chart Labs.
At Pop Chart Labs, they
basically do information-based
hierarchical charts like this.
And so, they were the ones that
designed the cover of the
book, as well.
And they'd done a previous
version of this map, and so we
were really trying to find
a way to maximize
space on the book.
Because in this day and age,
if you're going to have a
printed product, that you should
have something that's
going to be something you want
to hold that's going to be a
bit more permanent than
just another thing.
And design was such an important
thing for us on the
book, and so we tried to
maximize every last inch.
And so, what we did was, these
are basically all the beers--
I wish we could do the entire
chart, but you only have the
upside down part
of a book over.
But it's basically my favorite
picks and styles, and how they
kind of go to one another.
And it was a really--
I will tell you, I about
went crazy making
this with the guy.
And it was not fun.
But at the end--
because it was like totally
crazy, jibber jabber
scrabbling.
And I was trying to show him to
do and where to go, and I
was like, yeah.
It was fun.
But in the end, it turned out
great, and I'm very happy
about that.
But yeah, the book actually won
at the New York Book Show
awards, it won second place
for a graphic design.
Which was something
really rewarding.
And people were like, I
like the fact that it
has pictures in there.
And so I didn't realize
pictures were
such a boon for people.
I don't know if that's
supposed to make me
feel good or bad.
I was like, I wrote all
these words, but you
really like the pictures.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: What's your favorite
beer bar in the city?
JOSH BERNSTEIN: My beer
bar in the city?
Since I'm a cheap bastard, I
like Beer Craft, because you
can buy a growler of beer, and
then you can share with
people, and it's like--
as far as in the city, beer
bars I like going to--
you know, Blind Tiger is
nice, but I can never
actually get in there.
And I don't like--
it's always so crowded
on that.
Yeah, I don't like Ginger
Man at all.
Rattle & Hum's is OK.
Yeah, if you're nearby.
Other things--
Barcade's still a classic,
I think, for that.
And then, because I live in
that I neck of the woods,
sometimes I'll go down to 4th
Avenue, go up to Pacific
Standard, or Mission Dolores,
which are over
there in Park Slope.
And those are actually where
that 4th Avenue no man's land.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH BERNSTEIN: Yeah, The
Gate's good, too.
AUDIENCE: You been
to City Swiggers?
JOSH BERNSTEIN: I've been
to City Swiggers.
It's nice.
But living in Brooklyn, going up
to Upper East Side, for a--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH BERNSTEIN: Oh,
so easy for you.
For me, I got to--
I work out of my house, so it's
like, Upper East Side for
a beer, it's not exactly my--
AUDIENCE: We go to Pony
Bar now, too.
JOSH BERNSTEIN: You
go to what?
AUDIENCE: Pony Bar.
JOSH BERNSTEIN: Oh, Pony Bar
is open open up there, too.
Yeah, Pony Bar is
great, as well.
And that's the thing, the fact
that we can have a discussion
about what a great beer bars
there are in New York City.
It used to be 10 years ago, it
was The Gate, Blind Tiger,
Ginger Man and a few
other places.
But it's just that things have
been going gangbusters in such
a great way.
I always liked, too,
New York City--
sometimes, they get behind
in certain fields.
But New York City always plays
catch up in a big way.
So I think that's why you're
going to see craft beer really
take off here, that you're
going to see so many bars
popping up, and I mean--
I can't even tell you how many
projects are coming online.
The folks behind Heartland just
opened up a new brew pub
over on West Houston Street a
couple days ago, where they're
brewing a new line up of beer
specifically for that.
And so--
AUDIENCE: Is that part of the
Heartland diner thing that's--
JOSH BERNSTEIN: Heartland
Brew Pub yeah, a chain.
But those are more--
Heartland Diner, they did the
Heartland Brew Pub chain.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
serve food and stuff,
too, right?
JOSH BERNSTEIN: Yeah, there's
a bunch of them.
There's like six of them.
They're in [INAUDIBLE]
South Street, Seaport, Times
Square and stuff.
Just one of the few ones
that's not so overly
touristy-based, so.
Yeah, but it's every--
like, every week, a
new thing pops up.
And we're going to
see a ton new--
a ton new breweries coming
online, too,
this year, I think.
Especially within
the New York--
not just in New York City, but
around in Long Island,
breweries coming in upstate New
York that are going to be
coming into the city.
It's a pretty great time
to be a craft beer
fan in New York City.
Let me tell ya.